while the president is overseas the
White House is struggling with political
problems here at home officials face new
disclosures about FBI director James
Comey is firing the New York Times
reports the president bragged about his
decision to Russian diplomats the latest
CBS News nation tracker poll shows that
63% of Americans disapprove of the
president's handling of the FBI election
probe and 48% believe mr. Trump has
tried to interfere with the
investigation of his campaigns ties to
Russia Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill
with the latest on that story Nancy good
morning to you good morning well
senators will have a chance to ask James
Comey about his conversations with the
President and the memos that he kept now
that he has agreed to testify before the
Senate Intelligence Committee and it
comes at an important time because the
president's own recent statements about
this issue have only made the story
murkier the intent of that conversation
was to say what I'd like to do is move
beyond all of the the Russia news
National Security Adviser HR McMaster
was in the Oval Office but says he
doesn't recall exactly what President
Trump said to Russian officials
according to a transcript leaked to the
New York Times President Trump called
the former FBI director James Comey
a real nutjob who's firing lessoned
great pressure on the president because
of Russia
McMaster says mr. Trump didn't mean it
the way it sounds it's very difficult to
take a few lines to take a paragraph out
out of what or what appear to be notes
of that meeting and to be able to see
the full context of the conversation but
some lawmakers weren't swayed by that
explanation the fact is he has been
terminated but the reason for the
termination has really not been ferreted
out congressional probes are broadening
the House Intelligence Committee is
asking for documents and an interview
from former Trump campaign
communications advisor Michael Caputo
who worked in Russia in the 1990s and
with the Washington Post reporting that
a current top trump adviser is now
considered a person of interest to the
FBI some Democrats have begun to suggest
a White House cover-up there been so
many lies so many contradictions
the White House is trying to focus on
the task at hand and we'll be sending
Congress a budget tomorrow CBS News has
confirmed that that budget will include
800 billion dollars worth of cuts to
Medicaid over the next ten years we've
also learned that several top White
House officials like Reince Priebus and
Steve Bannon are leaving the president's
foreign trip early coming back home to
Washington in part Norah to make sure
that that budget rollout goes smoothly
Nancy thank you